wut über flugzeug abschuss viele iraner
fordern den rücktritt der
verantwortlichen und bekommen prominente
unterstützung
blindgänger alarm in dortmund weil im
stadtzentrum zwei fliegerbomben
entschärft werden müssen tausende aus
ihren wohnungen und zwei siege in zwei
tagen in val di fiemme verteidigt
skispringer karl geiger sein gelbes
trikot
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara halben abend und willkommen zu
einem schnellen nachrichtenüberblick
noch bei könig ist auch dabei für den
sport sehr guten amt die iranische
führung ist wegen des abschusses der
ukrainischen passagiermaschine weiter
unter druck auch heute trieb die
empörung über das späte geständnis
hunderte auf die straße us-präsident
trump stellte sich per twitter auf ihre
seite trump schrieb auf englisch und
auch auf farsi
es dürfe weder ein weiteres massaker an
friedlichen demonstranten geben noch
eine abschaltung des internets die welt
blicke auf die geschehnisse in iran aus
teheran jörg brase
es war nur ein paar hundert studenten am
abend auf dem asadi-platz in teheran
doch wieder gab es tränengas die
staatsmacht unterbindet jeden protest
sofort im regierungstreuen sender und
trat ein dozent der universität auf der
allen die weitere proteste organisieren
wollten drohte sie seien dann für die
toten verantwortlich die es bei der
niederschlagung dieser aufstände geben
werde
das vertrauen vieler in ihre führung ist
zerstört doch das regime wird versuchen
die lage ruhig zu halten und proteste
schon im keim zu ersticken
denn bilder wie vor zwei monaten als bei
den landesweiten demonstrationen
hunderte ums leben kamen wird man auf
jeden fall verhindern wollen aber auch
bei regierungstreuen zeitungen
beherrschten heute wut und enttäuschung
die schlagzeilen
schande titelte das blatt habe cherry
unter der schlagzeile unverzeihlich
stehen in der zeitung iran die namen
aller toten des flugzeugabsturzes vom
mittwoch sie haben es uns zu spät
erzählt das ist sehr traurig wir können
das nicht akzeptieren drei tage lang
haben sie uns lügen erzählt sie es jetzt
zugegeben haben können sie den fehler
wohl nicht länger unter dem deckel
halten wahrscheinlich war das flugzeug
der ukraine gehört das iranische
parlament beschloss heute einen
untersuchungsausschuss einzusetzen der
die verantwortlichen für den abschuss
benennen soll
viele aber lassen sich dadurch nicht
besänftigen trotz verboten vision
demonstranten auf andere plätze in der
hauptstadt aus noch sind es nur einige
hundert die meisten iranerinnen und
iraner machen vorerst noch die faust in
der tasche nach deutschland es gibt
offenbar immer mehr aggressionen gegen
kommunalpolitiker nach einer umfrage der
welt am sonntag sind in mehreren
bundesländern allein die polizeilich
erfassten straftaten gegen mandatsträger
2009/10 stark angestiegen vor allem in
ostdeutschland in thüringen von 43 auf
101 in sachsen verdoppelte sich die zahl
fast auf 197 ausnahme situation in
dortmund ein dicht besiedeltes
wohngebiet in der innenstadt musste
heute komplett geräumt werden weil dort
vier bomben aus dem zweiten weltkrieg
vermutet würden
andrea bögge über die größte evakuierung
der stadtgeschichte am frühen morgen
verlassen die letzten bewohner des
dortmunder klinik viertels ihre häuser
bis 8 uhr sollen sie den gefahrenbereich
rund um vier möglichen bombenfund
stellen verlassen haben
also ich sehe schon so dass das sein
muss
lieber so als wenn gesunde ding hochgeht
das betroffene stadtgebiet ein dicht
besiedeltes wohnviertel dortmunds die
evakuierungszone zieht um jeden
bombenverdachts punkt einen
sicherheitsradius von 500 metern schon
am vortag sind hunderte patienten zweier
großer kliniken einzeln verlegt worden
14.000 menschen insgesamt werden
evakuiert aber sollen die
herausforderung ist dass es schon von
menge eine kleinstadt ist die wir hier
evakuieren müssen und dass hierdurch die
beiden kliniken nahmen auch besonnen
rücksicht nehmen müssen auf die
intensivpatienten im betroffenen viertel
container schutzwände gegen
bombensplitter falls was schiefgeht der
verdacht auf 4 verborgene blindgänger
aus dem zweiten weltkrieg hat sich bei
der vorbereitung von bauprojekten
ergeben
ab dem nachmittag werden auch die nah
und fernverkehrsstrecken der bahn
gesperrt
das ergebnis am ende des tages zwei
blindgänger gibt es wirklich experten
entschärfen eine britische und eine
amerikanische 250 kilo fliegerbombe
am frühen abend dürfen die menschen
wieder in ihre häuser als
regierungspartei hat einen neuen
vorsitzenden morgen wird er zum
premierminister ernannt
es ist ein 42 jähriger jurist robert
abela wird nachfolger des umstrittenen
joseph muscat sein umfeld soll in den
mord an der journalistin dafne caruana
galizia verwickelt sein
galizia hatte über korruption
recherchiert 2017 wurde sie mit einer
autobombe ermordet zum zehnten mal jährt
sich heute der tag der haiti ohnehin
eines der ärmsten länder der welt in die
katastrophe stürzten
es ist kurz vor 17 uhr als hier rund um
die hauptstadt port o kurs die erde bebt
eine minute die hunderttausende in den
tod reißt und weit über einer million
menschen das zuhause nimmt nach dem
beben kommen helfer aus aller welt die
spendenbereitschaft ist riesig trotzdem
fehlt es den überlebenden heute an fast
allem dritter jäger mit seinem kleinen
laden für ersatzteile kann rehnelt
gerade so seine familie ernähren in
kanaan einer informellen siedlung weit
draußen vor den toren der hauptstadt
portugals lebt er mit seiner familie in
einem kleinen verschlag es gibt keine
toilette wenn es regnet spült das wasser
den schlamm herein
seit dem beben haben wir die situation
etwas verbessert und einen marktplatz
aufgebaut es gibt kleine geschäfte und
so was wie eine tankstelle
so kommen wir an geld 15 milliarden
dollar hatte die internationale
gemeinschaft nach dem beben zugesichert
und versprochen haiti wieder aufzubauen
besser als zuvor
doch nach wie vor haben zehntausende
kein richtiges dach über dem kopf
60 prozent der bevölkerung muss mit zwei
dollar am tag auskommen
22 prozent der kinder sind unterernährt
katastrophenhilfe fokussiert sich
meistens auf kurzzeit lösungen
wasserflaschen oder decken
keine überraschung also dass sie zehn
jahre später keinen nachhaltigen effekt
hat
armut und perspektivlosigkeit haben die
haitianer in den vergangenen monaten auf
die straße getrieben
quer durch alle gesellschaftsschichten
protest gegen korrupte regierungs und
wirtschaftseliten die das land auslaufen
solange wir denken können gab es immer
irgendeine krise in haiti
aber wir glauben dass es dieses mal
anders ist wir sind keine politiker die
an die macht wollen wir sind die
zivilgesellschaft zehn jahre nach dem
beben ist das leid nur wenig gelindert
eine korrupte regierung weiter an der
macht nun sind viele menschen in haiti
dabei die missstände im land selbst
anzupacken hat karl geiger einen echten
lauf zwei siege in zwei tagen das geht
in seine ganz persönliche
sportgeschichte ein
bei der vierschanzentournee hat es noch
nicht geklappt aber nach diesem
wochenende im weil die firma darf man
sagen karl geiger ist bis dato der
konstanteste und beste skispringer
dieses winters der
vierschanzentourneesieger dawid kubacki
aus polen ist einer der ersten
gratulanten karl geiger ist auch am
sonntag der beste von der normalschanze
und sichert sich seinen vierten weltcup
sieg als zweiter nach dem ersten sprung
auf starke 107 m behält er im final
durchgang die nerven fliegt bei
verkürztem anlauf auf 103 1 halb meter
und lässt damit den österreicher stefan
kraft und kubatzki hinter sich für
geiger nach seinem sieg gestern ein
perfektes wochenende an dem er die
führung im gesamt weltcup übernimmt auch
am käufer kann mit seiner heutigen
leistung zufrieden sein nur der franzose
manificat war schneller im
massenstartrennen zum abschluss der
biathlon tage in oberhof für
deutschlands beste handballer ist es
dagegen ein tag zur frustbewältigung
nach der pleite gegen spanien bei der em
heißt es nun die körperlichen und
mentalen kräfte sammeln für die
pflichtaufgabe gegen lettland morgen
abend läuft langes video studium in der
nacht training am vormittag so kommt
christian prokop zu den entscheidenden
erkenntnissen nach der klaren niederlage
gegen spanien
sie haben uns klar defizite aufgezeigt
die wir im moment noch haben unser ziel
ist es natürlich dass wir uns spiel für
spiel steigern dass wir uns entwickeln
dass man sich den weg einschlagen
die nationalmannschaft braucht dazu
einen andreas wolf in normalform
die technischen fehler müssen dringend
heruntergefahren
die konsequenz beim torwurf erhöht
werden auch und vor allem beim
kriselnden kapitän uwe gensheimer
natürlich möchte ich vorangehende möchte
wenn man leistung zeigen bin damit
bislang noch nicht zufrieden
das ist klar und dafür habe ich morgen
eine neue chance diagnose gestellt erste
therapie montag 18 05 10 gegen
außenseiter lettland und ganz aktuell
auch die deutschen volleyballerinnen
haben die olympia qualifikation nicht
geschafft 0 zu 3 gegen die türkei aber
die haben's geschafft
naja immerhin ja du bist ein guter
mensch fehlt noch das wetter morgen ist
es in alpennähe freundlich sonst sind
die wolken auf dicht hier und da wird
etwas regen oder es nieselt die
höchsttemperatur liegt zwischen 3 grad
in niederbayern und 10 grad im rheinland
die kommenden tage werden sehr mild im
nordwesten fällt etwas regen
marietta slomka begrüßt sie im heute
journal um zutritt vor 10
morgen um 19 uhr ist petra gerster zur
stelle
wir sagen tschüss und wünschen ihnen
einen schönen abend